Adventure has a name or actually it has
eight from the man himself to a literal
baby these are the actors who have
played the legendary archaeologists
Indiana Jones Harrison Ford first
appeared as Indiana Jones in 1981's
Raiders of the Lost Ark instantly
cementing the character's reputation as
a cinematic Legend after Raiders Ford
appeared in four more Jones Adventures
Temple of Doom the Last Crusade Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull and dial of Destiny
Ford is more or less Anonymous with
Indie which is all the more remarkable
considering George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg initially cast Tom Selleck for
the part look I did what I did I don't
expect you to be happy about it but
maybe it can do us both some good stalek
was too busy racing around Hawaii in a
red Ferrari on Magnum PI however and
four landed the role instead of course
Indiana Jones is just one of the iconic
characters Harrison Ford has played in
his illustrious career before Raiders he
had portrayed another of George Lucas's
swaggering Hot Shot Rogues Han Solo and
Star Wars he also starred as Rick
Deckard in the dystopian sci-fi classic
Blade Runner played Dr Richard Kimball
in The Fugitive kicked versus US
President James Marshall in Air Force
One the list is nearly endless in fact
and in the years since Raiders Ford has
become one of Hollywood's most iconic
actors not too shabby for an
ex-carpenter whoever Phoenix plays a
young Indiana Jones in the opening
sequence of the Last Crusade in the
third installment of the franchise Boy
Scout Indie takes on a gang of grave
robbers bent on stealing a golden
crucifix for mysterious benefactor
racing through the rugged Utah landscape
Indy does his best to thwart the thieves
but his efforts prove unsuccessful
it doesn't mean you have to like it
while they don't share any scenes in the
Last Crusade this wasn't the first time
Phoenix had crossed paths with Harrison
Ford he had previously played Ford's son
in 1986 says the mosquito Coast by the
time Phoenix took on the role of Indiana
Jones he was already one of Hollywood's
most promising young Stars he starred in
the 1986 Coming of Age Classics done by
me and at just 17 years old delivered an
oscar-nominated performance and Running
on Empty tragically Phoenix died in 1993
at age 23 from a drug overdose at the
time of Phoenix's death Ford told the
New York Times he played my son once and
I came to love him like a son and was
proud to watch him grow into a man of
such talent and integrity and compassion
veteran stage actor George Hall played
the elderly Indiana Jones and the young
Indiana Jones Chronicles episodes of the
young Indiana Jones Chronicles are
framed by old indie's memories and he
serves as narrator for the show's
Adventures although this older Indie was
edited out to the series when George
Lucas recuted as The Adventures of Young
Indiana Jones Indiana Jones came Layton
Hall's decades long acting career here
he trained at the neighborhood Playhouse
school and worked in Vaudeville before
hitting the Broadway stage in the 1940s
Paul died in 2002 at the age of 85
having performed on stage just weeks
before his death Sean Patrick Flannery
played a young Indie in the 90s series a
young Ileana Jones Chronicles as well as
several TV movies George Lucas hatched
the idea for a prequel series as a way
to answer fans questions about the
character he cast Flannery as Indie
because he embodied the enthusiastic
innocence that Lucas was looking for
I've got a bad feeling about this and
while Lucas intended the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles to educate as much as
entertained there's still plenty of
action and adventure to be had Flannery
a former autocross racer and triathletes
threw himself into the physically
demanding role of young Indie even
performing most of his own stunts the
role of Indiana Jones kicked off
Flannery's Hollywood career which
quickly moved into lead role Staters for
1995's Fantasy drama powder he made a
name for himself as a gritty action star
and this today best known for his part
in The Boondock Saints as for returning
as Indiana Jones well Flannery certainly
wouldn't turn down the opportunity as he
told pop culture in 2021 man I can
probably count on one hand the amount of
people that wouldn't want to do
something that George Lucas originated
Corey Kalia played an even younger
Indiana Jones and the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles depicting Indy as a
globetrotting nine-year-old under the
supervision of his parents Henry Jones
senior and Anna Jones carrier's version
of young Indie takes in the wonders of
the world and gets into a little trouble
along the way even young Indie didn't
want to be logged away in the classroom
for too long and his formative
experiences offer some welcome contacts
for the adult version of Indiana Jones
have all grown to love carrier
maintained an active acting career in
the 90s including roles as a young
Richard Nixon and director Oliver
Stone's 1995 film Nixon and Pinocchio's
mischievous charm lampwork in The
Adventures of Pinocchio since then
carrier has been living his life mostly
off screen yes for including the baby
too credited for just a single episode
Neil Boolean played an infant version of
Indiana Jones in the Indiana Jones
Chronicles little Henry grows up after
several scenes ready to take on more
mature childhood Adventures there'll be
a brief through Lane's performance gives
some important context to a famous part
of Indiana Jones law you know how it is
when you really like someone the first
time you ever meet them I mean really
like them well that's how it was with me
in Indiana boulane only has one other
credit to his name playing baby Jesus in
1995's Marie De Nazareth as he seems to
retired from acting around the same time
that he grew teeth as perhaps no
surprise that boulane's current
whereabouts remain unknown Chris
strombolis's depiction of Indiana Jones
might not be in the official Cannon but
his Tribute movie Raiders of the Lost
Ark the adaptation has become a
legendary feat of film fandom as a 10
year old living in Gulfport Mississippi
from polis and his friend dedicated much
of their childhood to remaking Raiders
of the Lost Ark seemed for scene an
undertaking that took seven years to
complete that's the way Sean paulus made
the project he later told the New York
Times I just wanted to be Indiana Jones
I wanted to see what it would be like to
be so self-sufficient and get in and out
of trouble in the years after its 1989
completion radius of the Lost Ark the
adaptation garnered a cult following
these days from polis has traded in his
Indie Fedora and a whip for a computer
with his LinkedIn page suggesting that
he works in animation and VFX welcome to
the drag Tony Cox plays Indiana Jones in
2008's Hollywood spoof Disaster Movie
joining a long tradition of Pop Culture
parodies of the iconic hero Indiana
Jones parodies are nothing new of course
and to Cox's portrayal of the man in the
heart isn't all that groundbreaking his
raunchy take on the character suits the
vibe of Disaster Movie to a t but that's
hardly a compliment considering the
movie currently says that a poultry one
percent on Rotten Tomatoes Tomato Meter
Indiana my ass still Cox's appearance in
such an atrocious movie doesn't mean
he's not a fine actor but film credits
dating back to 1980 Cox has scored parts
of movies ranging from Willow to
Beetlejuice to Bad Santa